two weeks into the UK's locked down and
deserted city scenes are testament to a
new way of life
most people staying home for as long as
science and the government decide they
must also on lockdown in Windsor Castle
her residents outside London the Queen
93 years old reminded Britain's that
this crisis too would pass we should
take comfort that while we may have more
still to endure better days will return
we will be with our friends again we
will be with our families again we will
meet again but the government is worried
about isolation fatigue and a minority
of people embracing the warm spring
weather to picnic and sunbathe in the
parks on promenade sand beaches the more
people follow the rules then the faster
we will all be through it so I say this
to this small minority of people who are
breaking the rules or pushing the
boundaries you're risking your own life
and the lives of others and you're
making it harder for us all banning all
this the ability to go outside to
exercise in public as the health
secretary has said he might have to do
would be intolerable to many
particularly those who live in cramped
apartments with no outside space only
compounding the effect isolation has on
physical and mental health but the
argument goes that if people aren't
going to change their behavior
themselves well then they might have to
be forced to in order to save lives
best friends amel and Gabriel are
keeping in touch at a safe distance
through the fence these two are best
friends and we're very good friends too
so I think that's one of the hardest
things about it so we're trying to be
responsible and we just come for a walk
once a day but this is really very
difficult as far as I know like this is
what the government has recommended you
get outside and you get as much Sun and
it's fresh air as you can obviously stay
away from people so I think we're doing
the social distancing quite well
with the police exercising emergency
powers to move people on it's expected
that Britain will get a pretty good idea
where the lockdown efforts have helped
reduce the peak when it comes in the
next week or so
but even then a way out of this crisis
involving eventual widespread community
testing and contact tracing to manage a
second wave
he's many weeks away yet Jonah hull
al-jazeera London